on count one for the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell the sentence will be life
imprisonment
the minimum term will be 42 years less
the time the defendant has already spent
on remand
on count two the attempted murder of
Joseph knee the sentence is life
imprisonment with a minimum term of 22
years
on count 3 wounding Cheryl Corbell with
intent to do Grievous bodily harm to
another the sentence is 10 years
imprisonment
on counts four and five the Firearms
offenses the sentence is 18 years
imprisonment on each
all those sentences are to be served
concurrently meaning that the shortest
period the defendant will be required to
serve before he can be considered for
early release from the sentence of life
imprisonment is 42 years less the 182
days he has served on remand